foreign
this is
um a big deal for me
so I recently had a great great friend
of mine
a award-winning multi-award-winning
um young adult author
and long long time great friend he is a
Rancher and a
an author and he is also a creative
writing teacher
um really an extraordinary guy
and we have many many similar viewpoints
on the world
and we also disagree big time on a few
big big issues
and I love him
and he has written some of the most
extraordinary books I'm I'm a sucker for
the old Where the Red Fern Grows and
Goonies and stand by me those old
stories where people are outside and
they're having adventures and um he his
name is Nate Dahlstrom so in the
interview you may you may hear me refer
to him as Nate he writes under the name
s j Dahlstrom and he's got a wild or
good Wilder good is the main character
um and it's a multi-book adventure
series and so if you don't have a
picture of what life without screens
looks like anymore these books are the
antidote
um BlackRock Brothers is just one of
them
um they're so extraordinary and I'm
gonna Link in the show notes
um to wildergood.com amazon.com where
you can pick up these books but I had
Nate on for
we did a long interview and we ended up
breaking it up into seven segments that
we're gonna release over the course of
the next few shows
but Nate and I have been
um through the ringer together in a few
a few big issues and we share similar
passions about things and we disagree on
some things like I said
but
in this upcoming segment
um
we're gonna really go down a rabbit hole
with some personal things that I don't
think I've talked about very much on
this show if at all about grief
and he has been one of my chief
Educators in my life on wrestling with
grief and dealing with grief and how you
show up
the right way
so this isn't an interview please don't
just skip over this one this is an
important one and this is a guy with a
lot of wisdom and a guy that iron
sharpens iron that um
I love sitting with and sharing time
with and sharing space with because it
makes me a better dad and it makes me a
better husband and it makes me a better
thinker and it makes me a better writer
and we all need people like that in our
life
but also Nate showed up for me in a
couple of places that um
will end up having a
changing my family tree sort of impact
so check out this conversation on Grief
this isn't an academic conversation this
is a honest honest conversation
about grief with me and my friend Nate
SJ Dahlstrom
trying to think there's those moments
you have in your life that there's
there's 10 or 15 across my life that I
can point back to and say I was
different after this I was different
after this
so
to put in context here's the story story
is
um
all through college I had this Basset
Hound that I loved just was my hound dog
slept in my vase up to my pillow slept
in your bed it was it was not great I
was not a hygienic before you were
married yes and um
then when we got married she got moved
to the couch and
when I took that dog she got sick when I
took that dog and put her down I I don't
remember my lifetime weeping that hard
like it was from my guts that was my
hound dog and I don't remember I mean I
remember you loving that dog but it was
Heavy yeah it is a terrible moment when
your buddy dies but then I immediately
Sheila and I went to the store and had a
rebound dog which is always a terrible
idea so we got another Basset Hound
within a week or two and her name was
Maria
she was terrible she was about as
worthless she was a walking football
just was not a good dog and then Hank
came along
so Hank comes along and that was his dog
and they sat around and he babbled and
she just laid there like a sealed giant
giant basset hounds do
so I took a job in another town and
Sheila was finishing up her dissertation
my wife was finishing up her research
and so
um we were traveling back and forth and
one day our families were going to spend
the day out of your Ranch and Marie had
gotten real sick and then she'd bit Hank
and it hurt him and then I took her to
the vet and the vet was like man she's
got she's real sick so I called Sheila
and said hey today's got to be the day
that I put this dog down and
I said y'all head out to the ranch and
I'll meet you out there
so I'm sitting there with this dog and
with that I don't like but this is
always just a hard moment it is Hank's
dog and
um how old is the dog at that point 10
or 11. yeah something like that and Hank
was um I think Hank was four I think
Hank was four
and you put a dog down and then you just
walk away and they put it in the some
City and Center City incinerator and uh
sitting there and I for some reason I
had this strange moment and I picked up
my cell phone and called you and said
hey this is weird it's seven in the
morning or eight in the morning I'm
sitting in a vet's office
would it be all right if I
I feel weird about leaving my dog here
and it feels like a right thing to do to
take the dog and bury it I don't know
where to bury it can I bring it out to
the ranch and you got real quiet and
there was a long beat it was one of
those that feels like 10 seconds so it's
probably two seconds
and you said if you don't take this
moment to teach your kid about death
you're not the father I thought you were
something like that something very
Nathan and it was something impactful so
judgmental but it was yeah and so we get
out to the ranch and
um you had set up a little shovel and a
big shovel and Hank and I went out and
dug a hole for that dog and we prayed
over that dog and we talked about that
dog and
I remember putting the dog in and Hank
saying hey don't bury the head and I
said no Hank the dogs the dogs die like
it was a it was a hard moment but then
two years five years ten years as I lost
grandparents and friends of mine
for a little little kid we called back
to that over and over and there was just
this moment of the importance of
teaching my son about grief and then
several years later uh maybe uh yeah
several years later
I get a call from My Wife and she is
she's crying so hard I can't hear on the
phone and I keep saying I'm at the law
school there working and I I can't
understand you can't understand you and
she had had an ectopic pregnancy that
had ruptured and
she had sat at home and we'd had several
pregnancy losses and she just said this
isn't happening it's not happening and
she tried to tough it out she's a tough
West Texas girl and then she'd almost
bled out in her living room and she had
driven herself to the hospital and then
called me on the way again I didn't know
what was going on I didn't even know
what ectopic pregnancy was I drive up
there and I had Hank had picked him up
from school and I saw my wife in a
wheelchair with the head of the OB GYN
and I remember looking at the doctor
thinking
oh this this is it like this this bad
somewhere along the way maybe I called
your wife or so I somebody came and got
Hank and I still don't know who came and
got Hank but I'm sitting by myself in
this waiting room and they were had
taken Sheila in and we're doing
emergency surgery on her and
um I just sitting there by myself I'm
just sitting there and then you walked
in and just sat right by me and you said
nothing we didn't talk and then when the
nurse came in and said we weren't able
to save the pregnancy but your wife's
gonna be okay I'll I remember I'll never
forget you reached over and grabbed my
shoe and you had you had tears that I
wasn't able to cry yet and that was an
important like just sitting with
somebody no words no nothing stitched on
a pillow just this heavy moment
but it was also an invitation to this is
what Sharon grief looks like with people
that you love you sit with them
and when I look back at our culture I
think one of the things we've done is
we've outsourced all these things to
other people and we've pathologized
discomfort we made just being
uncomfortable a bad thing that we have
to solve and fix
and when it comes to grief maybe the
number one question I get on this show
privately personally through social
media on the emailed in his questions on
how do I grieve what's the point why
don't we do this when we do this
talk to me because you've been a key
you've been a key teacher for me in a
couple of big areas on that
the the idea that you got to head into
the storm versus walking away from it
well those are
holy things and as your story manifests
uh What mattered was not anything
anybody said you know and so
uh
how do you show up to help and don't say
anything I don't know
obviously The Book of Job teaches us
that really carefully that we use said
Shiva with someone you sit seven days
and you just grieve and put ashes on
your head and tear your clothing and
don't give them a bunch of
uh mumbo-jumbo psychology or from the
sermon that said what do you tell
grieving people uh because you can sit
there and tell people what to tell
grieving people all day long and that
doesn't matter either uh because I guess
the answer is it's going to take a lot
of time and it's a lot of hard work uh
Jesus said I'm a Man of Sorrows and
acquainted with grief and you didn't get
that from reading a book yeah you know
you got that from uh being acquainted
with grief and nobody wants that yeah uh
it's a curse
it's knowledge you don't want to have
and so uh
to answer your question is uh
Solomon says if you want wisdom go to
the house of mourning and well nobody's
going to go to the house in the morning
uh they don't want that type of
knowledge but I mean uh
sit with people and be quiet but to
enter into that that kind of grief uh I
mean it's going to take something of you
uh you ever hear the
word poultice a poultice is something
somebody has a wound
maybe like a snake bite or something
there's some kind of poison you put this
poultice it can be like a piece of meat
it can be a a bunch of vegetation and
you put that poultice on the wound
and what happens is as the poultice
dries it sucks out the poison it's been
around for a long long time and so if
you choose to enter into somebody's
grief which is poison
you need to be ready to take on some of
that poison yourself carry it with them
and that's that's a really really dumb
thing to do
it's the right thing to do uh but you
know it's not
if you really jump into somebody's grief
you're going to get poisoned from them
and that's just you you can't in a
lifetime how many how many how many
people can you do that with very few
yeah uh until you look at our police
officers are burned the social workers
are birds the hospital attendees are
burnt it's just exhausting and and and
do it really honestly because that's you
know that kind of grief is a is a
Madness I've compared it to you know
like you know people probably don't get
this but to being in love and when you
fall in love you're you're everything is
kind of fake you're floating along On A
Cloud you're in a you're in a sub world
and that's what that kind of grief is
you're in a sub world nothing it looks
to you like it looks to everybody else
and uh
um but you know the gift of animals
if you're parenting properly in my
opinion
the animals teach you that first you
know your first dog you bury and if you
haven't sanitized that experience for
your kid and said oh the doggie went to
heaven and just go burn it and throw
away the ashes if you let somebody walk
through that well they've got a little
bit of a taste of what it's going to be
like when you marry Granddad
or a family member
and so that's a great gift that God gave
us that relationship you know with the
dog particularly uh which is really
unique like why don't we ball our eyes
out when dogs die uh you know it's that
little edinic relationship that slipped
through uh but uh but it matters and it
teaches you a little bit uh what that's
going to feel like because of course
life is a complete tragedy yeah just
over and over again we're just we're
just waiting for that the way I've
described grief or tried to wrap my head
around a definition it's it's the gap
between what you hoped for and what you
wanted and what actually happened and
there's that space and we run from it
and
it's been my experience that the longer
you run from it it the clot it doesn't
ever stop or there's that there's that
great quote uh pain deferred as pain
Amplified at some point you got to turn
and go in it and
um walk through it what's your wisdom
for somebody that's been avoiding it for
a long time
the wisdom for someone who's been
avoiding it for it for some time uh I
guess you're a West Texas Rancher you
just got work to do let's go do it let's
go get it done right
yeah I mean all I can say is what
happened to me and the only thing you
know why or why did we survive what
happened to us uh I I don't know nature
killed me it wasn't
people and you say well nature healed
you would that means nothing uh
I I'll just say this I remember one time
uh
I saw a deer in the morning in that time
come out and start eating oak leaves and
something kind of cracked and I think
what I figured that was was Beauty
is you have
incredible misery to go through in this
life and that's promised for sure
Genesis 3 there's a curse upon this
Earth you're waiting for cancer car
wreck but here's the one lucky thing
that happened that beauty got into
so while that curse got in a little bit
of the Beauty from the identic
experiences here and so that beauty
began to
patch me one to the next to the next to
the next and so a motto I developed in
those times was was defined Beauty
because you can for sure find ugly you
can for sure find the curse in the world
but if you find that beauty that beauty
you know of
I still have a friendship and it's
honest you know uh a sunset you know
wildflowers you know those things
literally began to save me if you if you
can make your whole life watching birds
come meet your bird feeder you know and
like when you're about when you're
drowning you know the beauty of birds
and and singing and the seasons all
those things it sounds trite but when
you're gasping for air five seconds of
air really matters yeah you're not
worried about the year of air you're
looking for the next five seconds of air
and and God allowed Beauty into the
world and it's all around us and uh if
you will sit there and wait on it that
beauty will get you through five seconds
and then ten seconds and then 15 seconds
and eventually you kind of make it
through the day uh
fine Beauty yeah that's
that's the answer
one of my favorite things is is
walking out of
especially back when we lived in the
same Community I'd walk out of grad
school
with all the PHD people sitting around
the table and then we'd head out to the
ranch
and one of the psychological constructs
they would pass along for instance would
be
what the brain focuses on is what the
brain sees everywhere and
as Neuroscience to that and then to go
sit with my buddy who's a rancher in
West Texas to say I'm gonna find beauty
there's a the answers in nature right we
can find in our textbooks but you can
live it here
yeah this is there you know those
fingerprints aren't everything he did
you know uh you you look really really
close out of Van Gogh you see the van
Gogh brush Strokes that are only Van
Gogh's uh and nobody else can do those
well you look really really close at the
footprints in the fingerprints all over
our natural world God is he's going to
speak to you and you have to be quiet
and listen and uh
it gives you just enough at the right
time
um but you know there's no there's just
there's no there's no quick fixes for
for any of that
um you got to be willing to take
somebody's poison and you've just gotta
wait on it and eventually maybe you'll
survive
oh surround yourself with beauty